Hello, this is Dr. Palmer,
and I am recording the
third and final of the
Rheumatologic Diseases Lectures,
and this is the one affecting
the muscle and skin.
There's going to
be a little bit of
blending here as far
as the systemic ones.
I didn't want to focus
on muscle, but we're also
going to involve connective
tissue as well, and the
first one is going to be
a little bit more systemic
as kind of a crossover.
So objectives are going
to be similar to previous
ones. We want to look
at, describe the presentation
and diagnostic test
used to diagnose mixed
connective tissue disorder,
the criteria for presentation
and diagnostic criteria
for dermatomyositis and
polymyositis, and then
we want to discuss the
presentations of vasculitis.
And that's a big section,
and we'll get to that.
It can be overwhelming,
but we will break it down
and kind of just help
introduce you to vasculitis.
And then we'll close with
discussing the overlap
of presentations with non
-rheumatologic diseases.
So what is mixed
connective tissue disease?
Patients have more than one
connective tissue disease.
An example would be
a patient who has
both lupus and
systemic sclerosis.
Most are ANA positive.
The key here is that you
want ribonucleoprotein, RMP.
So we want antibodies
against RMP and
that's usually a key
diagnostic feature.
So,
possible pathogenesis
is direct bonding to
endothelial cells,
immune complex formation.
There's a controversy to
diagnosis, and there's
plenty of need for research
here. Is this a version of
another illness, is it a
separate illness, is it,
you know, what is actually
going on here? So,
let's talk about who
gets this primary female
patient predominant, 35 to
50, and when you look at
the race, ethnicity,
typically it's associated
more with consistent with
the underlying disorder.
So, you must have
Raynaud Phenomenon. We
must have the puffy
digits or hand edema. Do
y'all remember the
term for puffy digits?
Okay.
Way back in the first
lecture, I asked you to go
back and look up that
definition. I didn't use the
word puffy digits. I gave
you the medical term.
So we must have the high
titer and anti-U1 RMP, and
again we must have some
combination of two of the
following, synovitis, myositis,
leukopenia, esophageal
dysmotility, paritis,
pericarditis, or interstitial
lung disease. So
remember when we look at
scleroderma and lupus,
there's a lot of overlap here.
we talked you know even
in the first lecture
about how there are
generalized findings such as
fatigue or myalgias,
joint pain low grade fever
again like I said typically
you're going to be
diagnosed with one
connective tissue disease
initially and then others
are going to be present
later so again we talked
about secondary Raynaud
so we have a concern and
then Raynaud comes up
the differential diagnosis.
And so the reason why
I put this here at the
beginning of this lecture
is mainly because of the
differential. I wanted y
'all to kind of be an in
-between. We talked about
rheumatoid arthritis initially
and then we've gotten
lupus, scleroderma,
Sjogren's in the second one.
Today we're going to talk
about polymyositis as
well and dermatomyositis.
We're not going to talk
about the other like graft
-versus-host eosinophilic
fasciitis, but again,
as far as this is kind of
an in-between between these
other conditions and
then the dermatomyositis.
So, speaking of that, let's
jump into dermatomyositis.
It is typically female
predominant, two to one.
From a dermatomyositis,
the typology here
is kind of a CD4, teen
lymphocyte, causing
damage to the paramecium
and blood vessels.
Versus polymyositis, we
get a different type of
damage. It's to the
endomysium of the muscle.
So when we look at incidences
here of these conditions,
it's going to occur in
peak incidences of 40 to
60 year olds and there's
also another peak in youngers
5 to 14 when we look at
polymyositis the proximal
bilateral muscle weakness
again proximal muscles
and it's on both sides
and it's weakness so and
typically leg weakness is
going to occur before the upper
extremity weakness. It's
not going to affect the
face, but there may be some
difficulty with swallowing
with polymyositis and
there's going to be pain.
Dermatomyositis is
classically with a skin
presentation, so we
may have a malar rash.
Remember what other
condition had a malar
rash? Okay, so lupus
is on the differential.
And we may also find
erythema on face, shoulders,
upper chest, and back.
We may find periorbital
edema, which is
referred to as the
helotrop rash, or gotron
papules. I'll show a
picture of that coming up.
And you may find
even some dilation
of the capillaries
and the nail folds.
So here's some pictures of
dermatomyositis, including
the gotron papules. And
we haven't gotten to
dermatology yet, but again,
we're talking about these are
raised rashes here that we
can see and we can feel.
This is the helotrope
rash, and this
is that nail fold
capillary dilation.
So if you were to
give a color to this,
what color would you
assign to this rash?
so historically we would
associate like a purplish color
to it a violaceous there is
an antysynthetase syndrome
and that's where they have
both PM and DM so both
polymyositis and and the
findings are similar to lupus
So to make these diagnoses,
you would expect an
elevated CK, would probably
perform a muscle biopsy,
remember that ANA table
and those other special
tests that we talked about,
those autoantibodies,
this is where anti
-Joe comes in, and it's
the most common one,
there are some other ones
that are associated, and
I've listed them here,
treatment of this is
corticosteroids, methotrexate,
IVIG. We want to
limit sun exposure.
And again, when we look at
the considerations here,
especially early on, there's
a high link association
with cancer. So this is
going to be one of those
where you're screening
and evaluating the patient
for other cancers that may
have not been identified.
So do they need colon
cancer screening, mammogram,
breast cancer screening,
are they smoking, do
we have any other risk
of other cancers? And so
you want to make sure
that they're getting all
their cancer screenings
and a full evaluation
because again making this
diagnosis is concerning
that they could also have
an underlying cancer.
On the polymyositis, you
know looking at the The
direction that that goes is
the anti-synthetase syndrome,
immune-mediated
necrotizing myopathy,
and then there's also sporadic
inclusion, body myositis,
and those are kind of
other subversions of these
conditions in the muscle
effects without the skin. I
talked about the myositis,
specific antibodies, anti-Jo,
there's the anti
-MI2, this one is
associated more
with cancer. Our
next condition we're
going to talk about is
polymyalgia rheumatica, ***
2 to 1, female and male.
It is thought to be a T
-cell immune reaction. You
have inflammation of the
proximal joint versus
in tendons, and that can
present with pain, stiffness
of the proximal neck,
shoulder, hips. Okay,
so the kinds are usually
like neck, like shoulder,
hip, girdles is the term,
very well bilateral.
You may have associated
malaise, fever, and
weight loss, but there's
no true weakness. One
of the things we talk
about is I feel weak.
Do they have good strength?
They may feel weak.
They may feel like they
just don't have any
energy, but when you
test their strength, they
actually will be strong.
So it's more pain
and stiffness, approximately,
but not weakness.
You can also have
elevated sed rate and CRP.
But again, unlike the
polymyosized, dermatomyosized,
the muscle protein
CK is going to be
normal here. There is
going to be an association
with giant cell arteritis.
And the question
about this being a
vascular pathogenesis.
So our next step is to
move into bacillitis. And
the treatment of this is
steroids and methotrexate.
So when we look at differential
diagnosis of myopathies,
so we'll look at the
autoimmune conditions. So we
talked about the polymyositis,
the dermatomyositis,
and like I said, these other
subtypes like the
inclusion body,
juvenile dermatomyositis, which
they're out there.
We're just not going to
talk about them today.
They're a little bit
more bare. I don't really
want to focus on the
polymyositis and
dermatomyositis today.
And again, when
we look at other
possibilities for
myopathies, includes
vasculitis, there's going
to be a lot of overlap
between lupus, rheumatoid,
Sjogren's, scleroderma,
RA, Sjogren's, okay?
But then we're getting
into other systemic
conditions. We have
endocrine disorders
such as hypothyroidism,
Cushing syndrome,
where your body makes
too much steroids.
You can have electrolyte
abnormalities that can be
causing this. You could have
a disorder of metabolism.
It could be due to drugs.
Medicines could cause
myopathy, micro-reactions.
You could have illnesses.
And so when you look
at, even when we get
into vasculitis, there's
infectious versions
of those, and you'll
have lectures on those.
Random myolysis is the
breakdown, so that's usually
found with trauma, crush
trauma, or heat illness
when you have too much
exertion, or maybe you're
laying immobilized for
a long period of time.
hypothermia can also do
that so that differential
of muscle muscle pain
weakness inflammation of
it's a wide differential
so we talked about
vasculitis briefly and so
this is inflammation of
blood vessels and again
it can be systemic or but
it can also be limited
to a single organ tissue
And again, I mentioned earlier
that there are infectious
causes, and you'll learn
more about this in your
cardiovascular portion,
but there's also the non
-infectious, and that's what
we're going to talk about here
is that, you know, again,
this is autoimmune genetic
predisposition leading
to environmental trigger.
It can be primary or
secondary, and like
I said, we're talking
about this because the
connection to all these
conditions is related.
the pathology is that
immune complex deposition
in the walls of the vessels
processing this again
activate complement
neutrophils, lysosomal enzymes
this causes damage
examples of this could be
iga vasculitis, pulmonary
arteritis nodosa where
there's a role for incas
which are anti-neutrophil
cytoplasmic antibodies.
If you remember that
chart, it was one of the
ones down at the bottom.
And these are also target
components of neutrophils,
monocytosomes, and
endothelial cells. There
is a couple conditions
associated with that.
There's anti-endothelial
cell antibodies
and autoreactive T-cells.
Now, over the course
of the next couple
semesters, you're going
to learn more about
these conditions in the
course themselves, but
we're going to give a brief
overview of them and
how they are defined.
So, we're going to
define non-infectious
vasculitis as including
large vessel, medium
vessel, small vessel,
and all vessel.
So, large vessels are two
examples here that we're
going to talk about today
are giant cell and tekiasu
arteritis. Medium vessels
include Berger, Kawasaki's, and
polyarteritis nodosa.
Small vessels are the MPO,
Pianca, and Sienca. And
then all vessels are Bechet
syndrome. Now, you may learn
more about these at different
times and some of the stuff
that I will cover. I do
want you to be able to
identify which one is large,
medium, small, and all
vessel. I do want that you
understand this slide and
understand which ones are which
because that plays a
role in presentation
and when you're
considering certain
conditions over
other conditions.
So this is kind of taking
what we just said in
words and putting it with
a picture, and we have
the large vessels like
the aorta and the larger
arteries, and that are
going to be, like I
said, your giant cell
arteritis, your tachyosus.
Now, if you go back here,
you know, Berger's here
in the medium vessel,
again, it could be
up here. Now, they do
break it down a little
bit differently, so we
have immune complex
mediated polyarteritis,
nodosa and Kawasaki's.
So it does put it
right here, but
again, it is kind
of more medium.
All vessel vasculitis is here.
And you can see
it affecting the
arterioles, the
venules, capillaries.
and so these often are
associated with the ancus
and usually you don't
see the immune complexes.
And on these, these
are the ones that are
immune complex
mediated. So we have the
lupus absciliatus,
HSP, or it's now IgA,
chiroglobulinemia
vascularitis, and good
pastures. And again,
you'll learn more about
these details as we
move on in the systems.
But again, remember that
these are autoimmune.
So large vessel, medium
vessel, small vessel.
So when do we consider
vasculitis as a problem?
systemic illness plus ischemia
that you otherwise can't
explain? So they have some
sort of other conditions
affecting all of the body,
you know, the ischemia,
but maybe an organ.
So we may find an
elevated SED rate, CRP.
Biopsy is going to be
what's really going to
key us in here, and we're
going to be thinking
about vasculitis with
that presentation and
involvement of the kidneys,
the lung, and the skin.
Okay, so skin diseases often
can be found as petechiae
and purpura, and we're
going to You're going to
get more of that in dermatology,
and that's just kind
of the presentation words,
language of the breath.
So our large vessel examples,
giant cell arteritis
and tekiasu arteritis.
So giant cell arteritis
is a granulomatous, T
-cell mediated, thinking
aorta and carotid, vertebral
and temporal arteries,
typically after the age of 50.
The presentation of this
is most likely more with
vision, so we will have
vision loss. This could
also be presented with
double vision and headache.
There may be some
weight loss, fever,
and fatigue, and typically it's
diagnosed from a
temporal artery biopsy.
So you have a 60-year
-old female patient
presenting with double
vision and a headache.
They may not have
that vision loss, but
this is where you're
going to think,
okay, I need to get
a sed rate and see
if this person has
giant cell arteritis.
and then biopsy is what
is done to confirm it.
Now, pekiastroarthritis is
also a granulomatous T cell
mediated but it is less
than age 50 so there's a key
difference. You may have
ocular disturbances, you
may have weakening of upper
extremity pulses and you
get fibrous thickening of
the aorta. So again, the
key thing here to distinguish
this is that There may
be eye disturbances, but
at the age is less than 50
versus giant cell arteritis
is over the age of 50.
So on to our medium vessel,
we have the Berger's
disease, and it is associated
with thrombosis and distal
ischemia in the extremities.
And this is typically
young males, less than 35.
They are heavy smokers.
They may present initially
with Raynaud's phenomenon.
on. It may have extreme
pain, but it can also even
be gangrene because it's
that bad. So you see the
gangrenous end of the fingers
and they're heavy smokers.
You're going to think
this is Berger's disease.
Polyarteritis nodosa is
also another necrotizing
type of medium vassal
vasculitis. It doesn't affect
the lungs, and so that's
important here comparing to
the other conditions that
we're about to see. It
affects skin, kidney, heart,
liver, GI tract in that
order. So it's predominantly
skin and then from the
other organs then you see
kidneys usually more so
than heart, more so than
liver, more so than the GI
tract. And again, it's
not associated with ancus.
It is associated with
hepatitis B though.
Kawasaki's disease, you'll
see this again in future
lecture. dermatology
pediatrics, I believe. It is a
mucrocutaneous lymph node
syndrome. It can also affect
coronary arteries, causing
aneurysms, thrombosis.
It is affecting young
children less than five years.
And it is associated
with acute febrile self
-limited illness, but you get a
delayed type hypersensitivity
reaction after the
viral infection trigger.
So in the small vessels,
we have ANCA-associated
one, and so this is the
microscopic polyangiitis,
and those are associated
with lungs and kidney.
We have the Wegener's
granulomatosis,
which is nasopharynx,
lungs, and kidney.
We have eosinophilic
granulomatosis, which was
historically called
Troeg-Strauss syndrome,
and that affects the
lung, heart, and CNS.
Again, you just need
to know that these
are ANCA-associated
small vessel conditions
and where they're
being affected.
More about the
pathophysiology of those are
going to be in the systems
that you're studying.
And again, diagnosis
of that is going to be
associated with like a
biopsy. Clinical suspicion
leading you to that and
then finding the biopsy
results. Immune complex
vasculitis, you may
find deposits of
immunoglobulin and complement,
glomerulophritus is
common, the IgA vasculitis,
Henochshondlin purpura
is what it used to be
known as and again
that's found in children.
The all-vessel one is
Bache's. It is more common and
more severe in males. It
has some HLA associations,
the B51, B5 alleles.
Typically more age 20s to
40s, average age 30, but
it can occur at any age.
And it's more common in
people from Middle East
and Asia, Turkey, region.
Classic presentation
is oral *******
ulcers, uveitis,
joint and muscle pain,
genotrack,
CNS, cardiovascular system
can also be affected.
These ulcerations
are the key here.
A diagnosis This
is made clinically.
There is a skin pathology
test, but generally
speaking, no laboratory
testing is required.
You have to have
recurrent oral out-dosis,
that's just the mouth
ulcers, and any two of
the following, eye
lesions, ******* lesions,
skin lesions, additional
symptoms of joint
pain, neurologic, or
vascular system symptoms.
The treatment is dependent
in on presentations,
steroids, indesuppressants,
colchicine.
There's no lifetime remission,
but you can maybe decrease
symptoms as they get over.
So let's review.
Treatment of vasculitis
generally is prednisone.
You can also consider
methotrexate or your
rituximab may require
disease-specific
treatments depending
on which one it is.
But vasculitis is hard.
Like I said, you have
to have that presentation,
that consideration.
Think the lungs
and the kidneys,
skin, and then a
biopsy as well.
Your differentials when we
consider here infectious
versus non-infectious?
Do we have concerns that
there's an infection
here with the vasculitis?
Are they taking a
cholesterol medicine,
statins that could be
causing the myopathy?
Are they having other
toxins, alcohol?
How does fibromyalgia
fit in here?
And label that as a neurologic
pain, fibromyalgia is not
an autoimmune condition.
Is there congenital?
I mean, have they been
fine up until adulthood
or has this been
an ongoing problem
since they were young?
Endocrine disorder is
the same kind of thing.
You know, was there
some sort of metabolism
disorder when they were
a child that's ongoing or
later if they've
developed hyperthyroidism?
Again, Again, we talked
about myopathy versus
weakness. Are they actually
weak or do they just feel
weak? Is there discernible
weakness on exam?
Reminder of fibromyalgia.
It is more common in women.
It is a disease of exclusion.
It is not autoimmune.
It can be at any age, but
typically in that
20 to 50s range.
It's associated with
chronic conditions,
including
rheumatologic diseases.
that's why I'm
mentioning it here.
There's no associations
with autoantibodies.
Review of these
tests, remember we
went over this here,
so we've got ANAs,
we've got strong
in the lupus with
the anti-DSDNA and
the anti-SMDNA.
When you look at
rheumatoid arthritis,
more with rheumatoid
factor. I do not have
the anti-CCP on here,
but it is associated
with the RA. We look
at Sjogren's ANAs with
rheumatoid factor and
anti-SSA and anti-SSB.
Look at the percentages here.
RA does not have this.
And again, Sjogren's,
remember the presentation
of dry eyes, dry mouth.
That's not associated
with RA directly.
So makes you think
more of this.
Diffused scleroderma, ANAs,
anti-SCL70, and again if you
check the anti-centromere,
you know it shows
the more limited
version of the Crest syndrome.
And then polymyositis,
dermatomyositis, you get
ANA, rheumatoid factor,
you get the anti-Joes
right here.
And then the anchors
may be a little
bit with lupus, but
again we're talking
about vasculitis.
So, some reminders
of other tests.
We've talked about
serum erythrocyte
sedimentation rate, the
ESR. We've talked about
the C-reactive protein.
I'm sorry for the typos.
Creatine kinase in the
The ANCA, historically
they were labeled as
C-ANCA and P-ANCA.
Again, the CK is
considered as a muscle
breakdown product, so
it's also found with heart
disease, so if someone
has a heart attack.
And then the acute phase
reactants can be, they can
go up with multiple conditions
and are typically not
used to diagnose specific
conditions, but when you
look at, like, say, primology
rheumatica and the giant
cell arteritis, having an
elevated ESR is important.
So that's the end of this
third lecture and the
end of the three lectures.
Review all the material
and make sure that
you can understand the
differences in the presentations
of these conditions.